hey what's up guys my name is a cello
and I finally did it alright I finally
made a proper system for you guys and
girls to actually get help with the game
programming series the multiple grant
program we said any series whether it be
networked a programming game programming
3d game programming whatever there is
now very streamlined system for you to
actually get help and this is it but
this is more than this right this is
more than just a help system this is my
website now this website is the chair no
calm ok I've revised it there's going to
be some really exciting things coming
coming up over the next a month or so
and even more exciting things coming up
further down the track but I'm not going
to get too much into this and one
explain to you what is already here so
first of all we have this main page
nothing exciting right this is going to
be like a you know for new paper blah
blah blah what this website is
essentially up here we have a couple of
links first of all you'll notice a
register link now if you use this
website which a lot of you do about 500
of you registered on this website
basically only for this poll if you have
an account on this website it will work
with this website ok you can hit login
all right and you'll actually be able to
login with your username and password
alright and I'll just wait for this load
so it might be a bit slow by the way
because I'm still transitioning and
optimizing it but you'll be able to log
in with your email address or username
and password now of course if you've
forgotten your password because there's
been a one or whatever there is a
request new password link over here
anyway back to this so that so in other
words you don't need to make a new
account if you had an account on this
website you can login with it on this
website as well alright so we have blog
we have game programming forums contact
login and register ok so if you haven't
made an account yet you can hit register
and you can register to that and I
highly advise you do that of course
because you'll be able to comment and
vote on poles as well as of course get
help now how do how do we get help I'll
talk about that first we have this
awesome thing called the forum ok
multiple forms actually there's one here
for 3d game programming 14 game
programming 14 network chat programming
and also also forums for collaboration
and showcasing your creations
all right maybe you're working on
something something else right maybe
you've just decided to I haven't a list
in episode of 3d game programming and
ages maybe you start to continue that
series but you're getting kind of lost
is that that would probably go into 3d
game programming or something but if
you're really getting sidetracked and
you're making new things and you're
trying to you know do things on your own
and you want to find people to
collaborate with then collaborations for
you or if you just want to show off how
awesome you are then showcases for you
and you'll be able to show off your
stuff now now I'll add more forums as it
comes up I haven't had too much time to
play around this comes like zero topics
each everyone who make an account will
be able to make a topic so let's say you
have a problem with game programming you
know your codes not working if you click
on that forum it will take you to that
forum you know eventually and you'll be
able to you'll be able to log in and
you'll be able to post new content in
the form all right and you'll be able to
get help because people will help you
I'll be scouring these forums um very
very frequently all right since you know
this is my website um but other people
will also be able to help you so before
I had this system of having a subreddit
alright and that wasn't too bad but a
subreddit maybe might not be the best
use for this since well it's a subreddit
and post get ranked by how popular they
are rather than you know if people
actually need help so not the best
system here but this this forum system
is going to be much better than that of
course now we also have like this blog
thing all right I've just made one post
on here so far but I will I do plan to
keep this up to date with with the
development of the website as well as
what's actually going on in my life as
well because I know a lot of you I'll
surprising the interest in that and of
course if you need to contact me or
something there is this contact page and
you'll be able to send minimum blah blah
alright so that's the website but the
main part again right now because
nothing else is really set in stone the
main part is the forums alright so
encourage all you to make an account if
you don't if you don't already have one
and and yeah and if you have any
questions about the game programming
series about any series that I do and
you need help because something is not
working for you this is the only place
to go alright if the question is more
than a simple one-line question if you
actually need a postcode or something
this is where you post it all right
thanks guys thanks for watching um quick
update by the way I University for me
finishes on the my loss examines on the
18th of November alright so after that
I'm going to freakin make a lot of
videos alright cool bye